we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
seemingly simple question about trump
take a listen
hello David I just wanted to get your
take on why no one's calling for Trump's
red resignation at this point in the
midst of all the crap that he's done
thank you right so listen you and I know
that Donald Trump has done you know
enough to warrant ten resignations and
five impeachments at this point I don't
know that there's much of a benefit to
calling for his resignation the
elections in four months right I mean we
if we reelect him if the country reelect
him after everything that's gone on
clearly the whack jobs are in the
majority I mean there's and and and
we're gonna have to figure out some
other way to fix the country I don't
know that there's much value in calling
for resignation now I think we should
focus on let's just get this guy out
were four months away he could be out in
six and we could have a different
president that's where I I'm not denying
he should resign I'm not denying he
should have been impeached at this point
I don't know what what we're really
hoping for because it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen we've got a great
bonus show for you today we'll talk
about the seattle protests zone we will
talk about the road block to electric
vehicles in america's future it's not a
bad road block we'll talk about it and
much much more join me on the bonus show
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show i'll see you then